the DeSantis campaign has a very
difficult task ahead of it and it has
had this task from the beginning so they
I hope they went into this with their
eyes wide open which is they need to
attack Donald Trump without attacking
Trump's voters they can kind of play all
around the field because he came out of
nowhere and he's not the number two guy
yet but DeSantis the strong was the
clear number two guy his only person
that he can take shots at is Trump and
he's got to win over a huge number of
trump voters who are unusually loyal to
their candidate and so he's got to
attack Trump while still sweet talking
the voters can he do that he hasn't done
it yet this is increasingly hard because
the Trump voters are not moving to
DeSantis so there's going to be an
Impulse among the DeSantis supporters
maybe not even among the official top
tier of the campaign but among the
middle and lower tiers of the campaign
to start going after those Trump voters
that will be death